i'm david reading for reviewer richard
wakeling like its cover star shohei
ohtani mlb the show 22 excels on the
field of play the action is largely
unchanged from last year's game aside
from a few incremental improvements to
aspects like fielding and ball physics
new additions to some of the series long
running modes are more significant but
they don't move the needle far enough
and as a result the show's year-to-year
progress since moving to next-gen
consoles is still glacially slow the
wind
that one is absolutely belted way back
and that one's gone into the bleachers
it's hard to have too many complaints
once you step onto the diamond however
hitting is still immensely satisfying
and tweaks to the game's ball physics
ensure that there's more hit variety
than ever before the thunderous crack of
the bat that occurs when you nail the
perfect timing and contact is
particularly pleasing especially when it
results in a soaring moonshot that sends
the ball careening into the bleachers
pinpoint pitching has also been refined
so it's not quite as easy to execute as
it was last year this results in more
walks base runners and high leverage
situations that feel more authentic to
the challenges pitchers face on a daily
basis the most noteworthy improvements
occur when fielding the ball as a
plethora of new animations make it a
much more smoother experience there's a
bigger separation between good and bad
fielders with gold glovers taking better
routes and reacting faster to fly balls
whereas their less than stellar
counterparts are more likely to commit
errors and misplay the ball this has
been the case in the past but it's much
more pronounced now because the players
act and play more naturally none of this
is groundbreaking of course but these
subtle improvements help maintain the
show's foothold as one of the best
playing sports games on the market other
additions to the on-field package are
cosmetic
there are some fancy new augmented
reality s graphics in the outfield
before first pitch but it's the new
commentary duo that has the biggest
impact
matt viscergen was the de facto voice of
the show having held the role of
play-by-play announcer since 2006
but he's now been replaced by cubs and
espn regular joe boogshambi chris
singleton is the latest in a revolving
door of color commentators and the new
broadcast booth does an admirable job of
calling the action adding new
perspective and anecdotes in between
plays without 15 years of built up lines
to pull from however there is more
repetition than in the past you'll hear
a number of phrases repeated over and
over again often in the very same game
singleton goes on the same spiel
whenever a batter isn't wearing batting
gloves for instance and you'll hear the
same line about a player being the full
package both on and off the field over
and over again more egregious are the
instances where they'll incorrectly
state the number of outs or recount the
history of fenway park when you're
playing at camden yards there also
shouldn't be situations where someone
like babe ruth is referred to as number
three but this occasionally happens with
both former and current players even
when their actual name is included in
the game with commentary lines singleton
and especially xiaomi provide a solid
baseline to build on for the future but
there are some growing pains right now
ground ball right side flores picks it
up
flores down to first he's out when it
comes to game modes mlb the show 22 adds
depth to the march to october mode by
extending it from a single one and done
season to multiple seasons this makes
what was otherwise a complimentary mode
feel more like an expedited alternative
to franchise with a full offseason of
trades and free agency signings to delve
into at the end of each year
franchise mode is still present of
course and expands on march to october's
truncated nature by letting you dive
into the minutia of baseball and running
a team there's not really much else to
say here though improved trade logic was
touted as a vital inclusion prior to
release but the cpu still has a habit of
trading its top stars for relative
peanuts developer sony san diego says a
patch is in the works to rectify this
issue but it's a bit concerning that a
noted improvement still isn't working as
intended and even if it was the show's
franchise mode is still lagging behind
some of its contemporaries being able to
customize leagues and divisions edit
draft classes and play online would all
be welcome additions as has been the
case for multiple entries in the
franchise mlb the show 22's career mode
road to the show is similarly lacking
anything compellingly new or
intriguingly different from what's come
before there are more live-action
podcast segments interspersed between
your on-field exploits with the likes of
ken griffey jr providing insight from a
player's perspective while minor league
managers and even a mental performance
coach explore other elements of being an
up-and-coming superstar these moments
are interesting but they're not always
pertinent and they don't really add
anything of note to your journey from
the minor leagues to the show thankfully
player progression is faster than it was
last year and you can now create
multiple ball players all with unique
appearances which was a major oversight
previously but without any meaningful
improvements road to the show is
beginning to wear thin diamond dynasty
also returns and remains one of the
better examples of the ultimate team
concept aside from being the most
generous card collecting mode on the
market mlb the show 22 adds a new single
player feature in the form of mini
seasons this lets you take your custom
team and compete for a playoff spot
against a handful of fictional ai teams
in a miniature league format games are
only three innings long so it's easy to
work your way through the season
relatively quickly earning program xp
completing missions and upgrading your
players as you go combine this with both
showdown and conquest and you have
plenty of fun building a fantasy roster
without ever venturing online if you do
want to face off against other players
however co-op is another new addition to
diamond dynasty's suite of modes you can
team up with one or two friends and play
in two on two or three on three matchups
against other human opponents there's no
genuine depth to these games since their
only one-off exhibitions and mlb the
show's take on baseball isn't
particularly conducive to engaging team
play as each player takes turns batting
pitching running and fielding as opposed
to working together by simultaneously
playing different positions it's an
enjoyable addition though with plenty of
room to grow in future installments mlb
the show 22 still plays a fantastic game
of baseball even if tweaks to fielding
and hit variety are mere subtle
improvements compared to anything more
impactful additions to march to october
and especially diamond dynasty enhanced
both modes while franchise and road to
the show continue to stagnate by doing
little else than treading water there's
still a ton of content to sink your
teeth into and mlb the show 22 will keep
you busy into the winter months but it
is difficult to ignore how conservative
the series has been for the past two
years this is an excellent sports game
just as mlb the show 21 was the problem
is that the list of reasons to upgrade
is getting smaller and smaller
[Applause]
oh this one's plastic
it's on its way out of here